Who says Disney princess don't really exist?
We came across ten real life people who look exactly like Disney royalty right down to their big wide eyes their facial exspressions and their beautiful hair.
These people have us convinced that with just the right amount of effort.
Anyone can transform themselves into their favorite princess.
Anyone can transform themselves into their favorite Princess. if this is your first time visiting our [channel].
Don't forget to subscribe and please give this video a big thumbs up! Because today we're sharing "Ten people" who shockingly look like Disney Princesses.
Belle makeup artist Richard Schafer from Orange County California admits he's addicted to Disney
And he spends most of his free time dressing up as some of his favorite Disney Princesses.
In this photo Richard is dressed up as elves and the resemblance between him and the princess is shocking!?
Wearing a long Brown Wig and a beautiful yellow gown to completed his transformation with some flawless makeup and very own prints.
Snow white.
Sarah ingle from Denver, Colorado spent more than
14 thousand dollars on custom-made costumes to transform herself into various Disney princesses.
Here she is it's a lovable snow white it took her about six months to have the dress designed and created and after putting on a
short black wig some bright red lipstick and dark eyeliner.
She looks almost identical to snow white all she's missing is a seven dwarfs and her Prince, of course.
Mulan when Ariana kwan was crowned to Miss, Michigan in 2016
Everyone couldn't help but notice her striking resemblance to Mulan.
The Chinese American beauty queen can practically be mulan twin.
They have the same eyes. The same round face and identical smile.
If Ariana ever decides to retire from the pageant world
We're pretty sure she can make a living as a Mulan impersonator.
Baby Moana.
Meet Elsa Rose Abadin.
she's an adorable little girl who looks exactly like baby Moana.
they have the same big beautiful brown eyes the same adorable chubby cheeks
And even the same facial expression. If the movie Moana ever makes its way to broadway
this cute baby should definitely be a part of the cast.
Rapunzel's Twin sister. Did you everything you'd see a real-life Rapunzel?
Neither did we until we came across this photo of Los Angeles actress and Model Skylar Vallo.
And we weren't the only ones to notice the similarities between skylar in the Disney princess.
She was actually hired by Disneyland in Anaheim California
To play rapunzel at the amusement park.
All it takes is 15 feet of hair extensions and rapunzel costumes and Skyler is a dead ringer for the Disney princess.
They even have the same wide smile a similar eye shape and the exact same hair color.
Real-life Ariel
Malaysian makeup artist Saraswati have some major skills when it comes to transforming herself into real life Disney Princesses.
Each of our transformations includes a hijab and combined some impeccable makeup
She definitely looks like she and ariel from the "little mermaid" or separated at birth.
She's even carrying around a fork just like the princess the resemblance is pretty shocking. Don't you agree?
The Filipino Pocahontas
Filipino model Sherrl Landsang of California,
may not be the same ethnicity as Pocahontas, but they have the exact same facial features
It's a mall of complexion
the same eye shape the exact same lips and the same beautiful hair.
Sherri works as a registered nurse and we're pretty sure she gets soft in the hospital's hallways all day long with people mistaking her for
the Disney Princess.
We're definitely convinced these feet are long-lost sisters
the Elsa lookalike
One of the most popular Disney princesses, Elsa from "Frozen"
has a real-life twin sister
lydia Luangta of reading, Berkshire
Discovers she resembled the ice princess after dressing up in announce a costume to entertain children at a local mall.
the registered nurse posed for pictures, and eventually
parents began hiring her to come to their children's birthday parties
Lydia takes her resemblance to also very seriously.
she has watched frozen over 30 times
So that she can really bring the Disney Princess to life.
The American Merida
An anonymous reddit user designed a medieval dress grabbed her bow and arrow and asked fellow rent users
If she resembled "Brave's" Merida. When her image ended up on the homepage of the website the answer was clear.
She's definitely marida's Identical twin!
The natural Redhead has the same wild and untamed hair as the Disney princess and the same doughty lift and she even has
A love for archery just like the princess!
Twinning with Jasmine
Olayinka Mia Noel of New York
Dressed up as a princess Jasmine for Halloween and her photo was so shocking that the image went viral.
People all over the world began telling her just how similar
She looks to be a latin character. She says Jasmine was always her favorite Disney princess and after purchasing for $10 costumes
She realized she's definitely 20 with the busy princess. When you place them side by side
It's definitely hard to tell who's who!
Witch of these real-life Disney princesses is your favorite?
React in the comment section below and don't forget give this video a big thumbs up!
Thank you!